Hola, mi nombre es Katy Beslado.
Soy directora de estrategia cuántica de IBM
e investigación de aplicaciones. Estoy aquí para desmentir
la mayor cantidad de mitos sobre computación cuántica
que sea posible en sesenta segundos.
Los computadores cuánticos son absolutamente reales
y tenemos dispositivos en la nube de IBM a los que cualquiera puede acceder.
Sí, pero solo para ciertas cosas en las que son realmente buenos,
como las matemáticas súper complejas con las que funciona el universo.
Pero si quieres hacer hojas de cálculo o enviar correos, usa
tu PC.
Sí, teóricamente, pero no
por ahora. Nadie ha construido una computadora suficientemente potente para hacer eso
todavía. En el futuro previsible vamos por buen camino,
y cuando lleguemos ahí vamos a cambiar la forma en que protegemos
la información.
Completamente falso. Los computadores cuánticos
son fundamentalmente distintos
y usan las leyes de la naturaleza para procesar información.
La IA de hoy corre en buenos y viejos dispositivos clásicos,
pero creemos que van a trabajar juntos en el futuro.
No es verdad. Tenemos un enorme ecosistema
de startups, universidades, laboratorios nacionales y socios de la industria que
usan nuestros dispositivos todos los días.
No. La computación cuántica inspirada lleva
mucho tiempo entre nosotros y corre en dispositivos clásicos.
Nunca cumplirá la promesa de la computación cuántica.
Si quieres computación cuántica de verdad, tienes que hacerlo con computadoras cuánticas reales.
computadoras.